donc l'actualité du jour c'est bien sûr
la mobilisation contre le projet de loi
travail de la ministre myiam elcomry qui
a continué ce jeudi 31 mars malgré le
mauvais temps les opposants à la réforme
du Code du travail se sont mobilisés à
Paris et en province toute la journée à
trappincar a emmené une cinquantaine de
manifestants de la CGT dans Paris le
départ de la journée d'action était
annoncé à 13h30 place d'Italie dans le
13e arrondissement arrondissement pardon
plusieurs syndicats sont à l'initiative
de cette manifestation la CGT Force
Ouvrière FSU solidaire et le syndicat
étudiants unf la CGT dénonce l'ensemble
du projet de loi soutenu par le
gouvernement écoutez ça s'attaque encore
une fois donc au droits qu'ont les
salariés dans le monde du travail qui
les protègent un peu par rapport aux
ambitions des employeurs euh donc qui a
tendance finalement encore une fois à
casser les droits des travailleurs
notamment face à un patronat qui est de
plus en plus agressif c'est une manière
de dire que de toute façon les
améliorations qui apporté suite au
mouvement du 9 mars ne nous conviennent
pas et qu'on demande et qu'on continuera
de demander le retrait pur et simple de
la loi comerie